China is making big strides towards
being the leader on renewable energy and
fighting climate change the US will
likely be falling back in the renewable
energy world under Donald Trump China
quickly becoming the alternative energy
leader and it's very interesting what's
going on we've been suggesting for
several weeks now probably a couple
months really that Germany politically
is likely to assume the role of leader
of the free world as it's called and in
terms of energy it looks like it's going
to be China we now have learned that
China has suspended 85 planned coal
power plants even the projects under
construction will no longer go ahead and
instead China's national energy
administration is going to put 2.5
trillion yuan which is about three
hundred and sixty 1 billion dollars into
renewable power between now and 2020
listen to these numbers this will
reportedly create about 13 million jobs
in renewable energy with an estimate
that wind hydro solar and nuclear will
contribute to about half of new
electricity generation by 2020 and I
know people will hear it and they'll say
yeah yeah yeah China China China it's
sometimes hard to understand how big of
a deal this is but this is gigantic when
you consider that China is up there with
the US as the two top energy consumers
China more energy consumption in total
than the US but less on a per person
basis this arguably represents the
single biggest move away from fossil
fuels in the history of mankind using
fossil fuels this is gigantic yeah I
think it's a great thing and it's great
that China being one of the biggest
polluters given their population is
about forefront of this and I would love
it if this sparked a friendly arms race
I guess and yeah fired other countries
to follow suit but I wouldn't expect the
United States to be there no here in the
US Rachel the conversation we've got
politicians campaigning on is who can
save the most coal jobs while China
meanwhile is putting three hundred and
sixty billion into alternative energy
we're not even having the right
conversation in the US we're not but I
haven't did in China they pledged I
think what was it 20% and the by by 2030
away from carbon yes
something significant yeah and I feel
like also they're trying to move away
from their overly samake
reputation okay well that's the other
thing which is China has a particularly
to do this as well many of their urban
areas are unlivable because of pollution
I was going to tell you that there are
thousands of deaths a year from
pollution in China and I remembered the
stat rung it's thousands of deaths per
day 4,400 deaths per day in China
because of polluted air so yes China has
a particularly acute need to do this but
whatever the reason is they are very
quickly becoming the leaders when it
comes to this and I wish that our
politicians in the US could understand
especially Republicans because they're
the most against from moving away from
fossil fuels the leader with alternative
energy gains not only an economic
advantage but a geopolitical diplomatic
advantage because when you say hey we're
country X and we really need to make
progress and go to the authority on the
future of energy do we go to Trump who's
trying to save coal jobs or do we go to
China which has invested this amount of
money in renewable energy I think the
answer is obvious and Republicans seem
to be missing the point send me your
thoughts about this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman we'll take a break and be back
after this Gamefly is sort of like
netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low use
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you would return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the David
Pakman show audience and support our
show by going to Gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s